[Musique]
tout en vrac avec tu vois on va c'est
pas du média chantier ardisson drôles ou
qui se déguise pas en soi rien a
toujours un an la foi et christiane bien
on terminera le top16 après camille a
oui c'est sûr notre président emmanuel
bacon énorme salut manouche que je
comprends la liste superbe tellement tu
vas et orange et les branches ou
benjamin chèque à donner je le donnerai
plus tard si bébé halloween t'es pas
déguiser et ben j et non je suis arrivé
trop tard au stylisme en etienne daho
week end arrivé j'avais plus que ça bon
tout le monde va bien oui bien commun à
tous j'ai pas ce que ça veut dire si
jean paillasson de loisirs au début il
adresse également tenu je voulais des
bonbons la mise à jour la mise en page
les images les plus ouvre de ces
dernières 24 heures c'est l'ama a jasé
la maj bébé ok on y va on appelait
regarder qu'un vieux copains nous des
rixes et a fait un christ en plein
direct fait plaisir d'avoir celle
prononcée en appel en 2012 lors d'un
procès qui avait été
c'est le charme lors du si on avait un
mot là-dessus sur france 3 bienvenue
dans les bêtisiers de noël mon petit
bonhomme va retrouver le podium de la
ligue 1 après sa victoire contre metz 2
buts à 0 ben ouais ça arrive à on a pris
notre ancien président nicolas sarkozy a
décidé de passer les castings de la
prochaine saison de nouvelle star sur
les dj la réponse aujourd'hui à une
aventure avec notre valeur renfort de
stars non la vraie délire gallery dès ce
soir
marc est hachée par idc ton cul cul qui
ripe ncc me mettre en valeur
je me suis bien dans la maison barras
curly diabolo menthe 33 jours mais là je
gardais muriel robin moi je l'attends
l'hebdo qu on en parlait mais les
éléphants
je suis juste eu un petit peu mission
sur les éléphants menacé d'instruction
et là bas elle a rencontré des gars
vraiment des gens avec qui elle a
partagé des vrais moments moment de
partage très riche
quasiment une deuxième famille et le
quasiment est un montant à c'est un peu
chez nous
busacca vous savez on a découvert que
muriel adore les mêmes choses que j'en
ai aussi on a mal je me suis comme ça la
tdf que nous savons pas qui est à
l'origine du déguisement aussi en voici
quelques-uns des meilleurs regardent et
attendent les ponts je vois la bombe
aussi directe à la fin à ces pratiques
maintenant c'est normalement il y avait
un autre truc avant apparemment images
passion ont régi vous êtes au 1er
novembre
à bas les gascons barillet 20h50 je
bousille tu as trop tard les mecs
comment on oui on est là c'est un
déguisement pascal havane était super
c'était vraiment un bon moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si j'ai envie d'enchaîner
mais si la grèce va t il se dit qu'est
ce qu'ils vont ils sont prises
facultative à quatre ils vont envoyer
pour envoyer j'en suis là c'est vrai
qu'il me demandiez ce que j'ai pris
vidéo schumacher que vous n'aviez ce que
j'ai prévu de faire ce week end c'est
elle qui serait prévu de faire ce
week-end par un spécial et un truc c'est
que j'adore 26 boutiques sais c'est que
c'est comme dans une boutique ils
veulent te mettre un peu la pression
pour tâche est le truc c'est le principe
de du téléshopping donc ils partent
parfois sur le fait que les stocks sont
quasi-vides palette reprennent un peu
pour des cons quand même déjà le
visuellement les changements entre avec
et sans dans le pen partie puissante 5
attention il m'en reste déjà que 461
peu de marge en chasseur la partie à une
candidate est une expression biellette
pour dire qu'elle n'est pas venue pour
faire de la figuration ce bar de semaine
sarah n'a rien lâché pour trouver le
bien parfait pour sophie et guillaume 1
je suis quand même là pour gagner un je
suis pas là pour tricoter des pulls à
isabelle on a découvert le marchand de
tapis le plus drôle et le plus honnête
au monde
on pourra pas ce qui concerne le tapis
volant ces pratiques comme annoncé il
parle du fait de vider dans la pétale
maillot de bain son petit frère de 10
ans il en avait pas d'autres le haka
pays n'est pas prêt de disparaître tout
ce qui passait sa vie bat ça lui va très
bien
[Rires]
vous aimez les sons les garçons en quoi
vous payer un string caleçon boxer faire
à auxerre scène entre les secrets n'ont
trompé son mari benhaim pas faire boxer
facetime
auxerre aussi j'ai été béni oui oui mais
du coup j'ai le choix là j'hésite est un
peu trop cool moi non c'est pas
maintenant on est bien elle est libre
voilà je suis allé un peu ça dépend de
personne mais j'ai vu tout de suite et
dès que j'ai vu j'ai dit ça sert à quoi
vous avez déjà le pays ça c'est une
femme tubes gaby blessure à lui qui est
en huit ans il est banni temps ci les
pigeons slop grâce à toute mon équipe
composée de moi même j'ai regardé toute
la télé notamment les jeux télé tous les
gars
il a alors dans mon motus notamment ray
a donné le droit à la candidate qui est
un peu trop détente concept un peu trop
détendue je pense qu'elle pense qu'elle
joue tout seul dans son salon riad
somnambule s om n a nb ul eux au verbe
pardon pardon je sais vous adorez sacyr
et là que pour vous lolo romejko avec
animalière même bertrand renard en plus
grand pour tout donné ils sont très
vulnérables quand ils sont en troupeau
la nuit parce que la nuit ce sont les
viols et les panthères ont et en
particulier les petits impala de
matières en vite que quand le lion
arriver dit il plus la séquence annuel
le new way et dans ce cas vous regardez
ce stage de plus en plus des gens on a
un candidat dont le père exerce un
métier particulier jean-mi on allait
coordonner auront-elles taketa c'est la
thématique du jeu on en parlait tout à
l'heure c'est votre votre épouse et les
spécialistes de quoi philippe du coup
sur le testicule justement à ba voila
voila mais encore plus regardée dans la
même émission on a totalement perdu un
candidat ils oublient les caméras et les
micros quand il lui vient une bonne
valorial 28 mois à 28 donc plus que les
2 d'acajou 28 sur les noces 2 de nickel
nickel oui mais demain je vais me
verrais pas pourquoi ai je pensé la même
chose en même temps bien voyez comme
brad plats salés sur france 3 et là bas
la place à des la balle et tout show de
boucane dont le secteur est bien sûr
mais moi de médication général des 12
coups de midi
non williams et diffuser mois date apple
corps pour réaliser pouces coup de
williams avec des copains ouais mais ça
va arriver très vite peut être comme toi
et william leymergie les tous les midis
sur layon mais la marche de mieux en
mieux
ouais ça commence à 12h40 on l'a dit
hier soir la star ac c'est hélas évoqué
ni d'ailleurs les projets sont sur lui à
lille à toi tu te fais tout petit mon
gars d'accord je me sens trahi qui sont
la philo chez william leymergie recevant
un grand rappeur français on sent que
william hill et hop tu as vu d'un ami
nan nan nan il est prévu de recevoir
tout bien tout bien on parlait de
musique maintenant et vous allez
retrouver quelqu'un vous n'aviez pas
entendu depuis quoi une bonne dizaine
d'année 1 même si cela est oui il est de
retour après dix ans d'absence
j'ai tellement fait que quand il le cite
ses tubes sur le plateau de m6 solar tu
peuple ne peut pas s'empêcher de rap est
un peu on s'y croirait bientôt dans les
bacs cadeaux
bush de la deuxième récolte le tempo à
hiesse sinon sur la langue française
encore pris 2,3 de torgnoles dans la
tronche que des lapsus même nos
politiques ont besoin de vacances
visiblement regarder a été diversement
accueillie par les habitants
un collectif 1 pour que la cuillère la
cayolle la guyane d'école pour arrêter
un nouveau plan national alors françois
qu'elles sont dits intéressés ce travail
formidable quelques initiés jean louis
borloo et pour halloween un parc
aquatique regarde jouer et montrer cette
image a réalisé le gag le plus flippant
mensuel est bon et horizons
d'ailleurs en parlant de deux caméras
cachées la semaine prochaine du rallye
prendra sera mercredi prochain
1 vous savez ce sera en direct sur s'est
vite j'aime beaucoup ce que je vois là
jusqu'à 1
après bon je suis chanson là ok ça aille
acheter des boules boule de nerfs une
boule de nerfs j'étais chaud sont au
rouge au magazine de la santé regarder
ça j'aime pas 16 ans rien dire ils sont
contre la fois ton frère au calme l'air
de rien regardé dsk qui passe et bill
c'est le sosie du gard
ils ont pensé mon père finances dans les
anges on a trouvé la fille qui a pas
compris le principe du mal de mer oui
et personne
moi j'ai une même personne de madère et
les émissions de boulangerie carton dans
son record pour le meilleur pâtissier
here on attendu est celui qui nourrit
pardon le meilleur projet qui
participera pas à l'émission
une cliente lui avait demandé d'écrire
heureux anniversaire en polonais elle a
reçu ce gâteau
joyeux anniversaire en polo d'écossé sur
les raisons et envoyé sa chance et merci
aux gens qui nous envoient des chemins
sur les rythmes d'un point et tu sais
mettront lumière attaque on va en faire
il ya les recrues ce qui arrive en plein
chantier dit bah on a le temps je veux
juste répondra aux gens depuis ya plein
de gens qui m'arrêtent dans la rue
qu'ils disent oui la chronique est alors
depuis deux jours nous on a changé de
rein de passer à l'heure d'hiver en fait
c'est pour ça un bateau comme ça je me
sens bien encore quelques trucs à dire
je pouffe pas là consorts allez vas-y
est franchement vas-y mais ce que tu
veux ça dans la gueule crg prendre ta
gueule pour un buzzer on a rencontré un
papa c'est le plus beau paquebot pape a
d'ailleurs du monde il nous le présente
comme ça comme un très beau papa parfait
mais en une seconde le fils qui a qui
rend un coup de main parle et tout
s'écroule sur toute sa petite tribu et
il remplit très bien son rôle de papa de
substitution
ça a donné quoi il ya ton truc que j'ai
fait et paul dewar dominique a passé une
tête dans le public de midi en france
bat le père noël tranquille ou ya alors
le chassé-croisé du réveillon a pas
démarré il était là pour halloween aussi
fait attention pas tout le monde prend
super bien les blagues vous allez voir
on est un peu déçu parce qu'on parle d'
halloween et le costume de gilles hier
soir était bonne jument mieux que ce
soir il y avait en train de nous faire
ma fille dit ni sur les intrus c'est
quoi on s'accroche directement dans les
émissions télé dans les clips tout ça
pour être sûr de ne rien rater son oui
oui ma carte bleue pour vous conseiller
trucks a d'ailleurs enterré là guy
[Rires]
welsch pascal le grand frère
l'usa assagi iuf avant jc renaît
aujourd'hui je suis tel d'unibet quoi
calmos 1 est d'accord comprend pas
[Musique]
souhaitons-lui aujourd'hui d'entretenir
un peu la flamme il doit quoi qu'il
arrive
sebastian vettel terminer dans les deux
premiers sinon au delà quel que soit le
résultat d oui c'est little c'est le
britannique qui sera champion du monde
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui vent
assurez-vous toujours la banane toujours
debout
fout mal barré
le prix d'un ticket premier coup franc
pour le paris saint germain à un peu
plus de 1000 de jeu c'est angel di maria
qui passe en charge et deux minutes de
jeu c'est con parisiens sont capables de
marquer d'entrée
[Applaudissements]